jean d'ormesson vous dites à un moment
donné dans votre livre que m'a beaucoup
frappé que vous n'avez jamais été menacé
par la stérilité et par la difficulté
d'écrire et vous venez de l'eau dire que
c'est en prison que vous avez été formé
quand vous êtes arrivé en occident
est-ce que vous avez craint de trouver
tout à coup dans ce milieu nouveau une
difficulté d'écrire est ce que le fait
de ne plus être sous cette pression que
vous avez si bien décrite est ce que ça
ne vous a pas fait peur
voilà une question de technique
littéraire je voulais imposer en annexe
mais je ne sais pas si vous y répondre
et une question beaucoup plus large
c'est ce nouveau au milieu où vous vous
trouvez
cet occident à la fois si transparent
est si inquiet sur lui même qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
donc il ya deux questions la pub
littéraire alors la question littéraire
d'abord d'un passing
j'ai produit un effet cette crainte
acheté 6 à 6 et si on fils tant que sami
je vais cesser d'écrire non aux tamouls
mais ado non pas parce que je pense
temps d'aller y et du peigne est il a pu
se rendre à venir il se serait d'écrire
nipayia thomas c'était fade ligne hier
nation eskasoni pour juillet j'ai de mon
côté je crois du resort inter dab ligne
mini l'impression aussi bien dans les
divers pays auprès d'ibm et j'avais plus
la nécessité
je vais pas revenir sur extérieur
hospital elle m'a éduquée et bastad
suède et je crois que j'ai été suffisant
on vous montre signé pour générer leurs
semis notamment ne me quittera jamais et
donc un coeur et un vietnamien
comme vous le savez que ce n'est pas guy
boucher le coq chante dans le choeur que
louvier tous les cas toutes les victimes
qui n'ont pas daigné tolcachir mag
appris que j étais de machine à raconter
leur épreuve avant-hier cseries dont je
vous parle ces listes on est aussi dans
l'histoire qui nous est commune tous les
documents s'installèrent chien bruni
n'est pas obligé par les races ya
jusqu'à maintenant
il est heureusement je suis à la
possibilité d'exprimer quelque chose de
dire que la paillasse
je profite à fond prostrés la star agnès
heureusement il s'est toujours arrangé
chimie
la séparation en jeu mon milieu naturel
il c'est le seul moyen c'est un monstre
et je me trouvais dans les conditions de
levée gobbi qu'il n'ait cherché des
destructeurs faire le travail sur mes
capacités
il craignait ce match il est en effet
d'ailleurs sa wii qui jouait pas
directement leur animal pour moi c'est
moi j'avais aussi des noms suivent le
punir ces espèces de bienveillance de
masse qui m'entouraient le moment je ne
lui dis serait bien avant de me voir
pendant une demi heure
évidemment une réponse en quelques
lignes mais ça allait mais cristiano jr
ne peut s'appuyer ce courrier il est
proche d'antoine je renvoie une préface
tout que je leur envoie signé ou peu
gras riches états unis et qui sait à
l'évolution de l'intensité dans une
société où verhaeghe par mois passent un
style comme chez nous mais d'autres
voitures et demande autre péril notre
don juan on assiste à un sacré il ya un
de mes valises et de mighty séduire
bouillie au studio white boy à split
situé d'où on va te becqueter que
picorer et si tu seras amer on va peut
cracher sur étaples ignatieff et innove
tout le monde n'y a ni d'écrivain il ya
plus d'hommes de plus personne
si à votre classe date sirani refusé à
tout le monde s'est vexé non c'est cela
qui fait si un écrivain du 2e siècle
bourse et berrechid pouvait se permettre
vichy est la piste séchait erding ou
lettres de ses lecteurs c'était que n'y
avait pas tellement d'hommes les traits
au format la formation n'allait pas si
vite à sitges mais aujourd'hui à
coopérer
j'ai pu répondre à tapas reste et ce
danger ne viendra à notre match sur mon
côté j'aurais pu me noyer au fond
pendant cette année choisi le gérant
chez vous dis ce que tu veux être un
mélange entre mignard demande est
relatif des montagnes de l'être ridha
machinistes relais où les magistrats
labonté est clos a tué mon équipe isme
on n'arrive même pas à les ouvrir et
décacheté il ya les stars annoncées
alors je suis parti dans la montagne je
me suis mis à travers pièce s'inspire
heureusement avec quelques fenêtres qui
niveau déterminé ce livre aussi licence
iliad et et je continue à travailler au
suivant